[Music]
for coffee connoisseurs and discerning
caffeine addicts the Aerobie Aeropress
is a good move for a quick brew just
slip in a filter and grind your own
beans to fill the main cylinder you
roasted them yourself right and pick
them fill it with piping hot water not
too hot you Philistine seriously though
French presses and other coffee makers
can leave grounds sitting in water
results coffee with a side of rib but
the Aeropress pressurizes coffee
directly into your mug - those
irritating solid particles and voila a
cup as strong and flavorful as French
press and as clean as drip - the hassle
of both
[Music]